[Music]
so
welcome everyone to the board meeting
um monday the 11th of april
the kai foreign community board meeting
so i've already noted apologies from
neville
and sandra for has sandagon already no
she's still there sandra's going to be
leaving early is that right and so is
phillip
okay thank you and there's an apology
from chris greengrass as well
i think that's probably everybody
so
i'll move those apologies can someone
second them
john so i moved by me second by john all
those in favor all right against
carried thank you
are there any conflicts of interest on
tonight's gender
nope okay
confirmation of minutes
i'll recommend that the minutes um
that have been circulated how of the
meeting held on the 21st of march are a
true and accurate record do i have a
seconder
more than happy madam chair
brent thank you seconded by brent all
those in favor
against
carried thank you
are there any matters of reporting in
progress
no
matters arising
no all right we'll move on
so first up tonight then is a
presentation um or deputation from
wow and aqua new zealand equilibrium new
zealand um tony and
i've forgotten your name that's terrible
tony and
jason
thank you jason sorry about that
had a nice chat with toni
just fyi boys who remembered me
i had a great chat with them at the
closing day which was very well attended
i must say it was a fabulous day the
weather was perfect so you're going to
tell us um how things have been um
having had now um
six months i suppose that you've had
there is that right
yeah six months three months of actual
uh
um time
on the water um so what i'll quickly do
is show you a video for those that
didn't manage to get down and i know we
saw a lot of your faces there uh just a
wee bit of overview of what the project
looked like
and unfortunately young mark's up a
mountain somewhere chasing deer so he
couldn't make it today but he's done a
little download as as the director of
aqua landing zed so i'll play the movie
and then i'll flick over to his little
update for you
thank you
[Music]
so
very good but a bit of a flavour and as
you saw we sort of measure success and
smiles per hour
and yeah
it was amazing to just see those looks
of exhaustion
and enjoyment coming off the park so
just quickly pull up um
mark's little piece now i hope you can
hear the volume on this it should
transfer okay
but he's just going to give you a bit of
an update on some of the data
hey guys um
to
run through some of the season's uh
highs and
also some of the great things that we've
done and look at what we're doing for
season two but firstly i just like to
say thank you very much for your support
and ongoing support to help get this
project off the ground
um
yeah this means a lot to me
this whole
sports facility that
is pushing and yeah
thank you again for your support um just
a few of the
[Music]
attendants or visitors so we had over
the season 15 000 users
which equated in almost
30 000 visitors so we
[Music]
could tell that it's almost one to one
everyone was turning up with a spectator
at least or even two
so that 30 000 could even be on the low
side
with all the data that we produced at 96
of our visitors were from the south
island four percent north island uh and
were from out of wyoming
area
so
you know there's 80
and this was a mix of charities
schools and non-for profits and one of
those
profits that stood out was pillars
now pillars is a
big brother system for kids who don't
have their support networks they provide
a big brother for
kids in need and
the
response from the company and the kids
uh
qualifications
or the right skill
then we provided that training for them
to upskill them
for season two
we are looking to explain uh sorry
expand the inflatable offering so
we're looking to provide a few more
features in this area here
uh to
cater for
small and old
so
younger and older people just to expand
that offering
uh we want to improve the online
facilities
so
provide some more shelters and tables
and chairs a bit more of a hangout spot
um
and we're also looking at um putting in
a transitional cable accommodation and
surf
uh
however this is just
my piece here
i really hope um
you
have received a lot of good feedback
it's been an incredible season
um have had a few highs and lows
um
from
covert changing and
having a really wet season however it's
been
an awesome learning experience for all
of us and we can't wait to come back
stronger next season so again thank you
very much
and look forward to season two
thank you very much that's great it
sounds very positive um report thank you
for that
tony
yeah i'll let jacqueline jose carry on
for for a minute
right
we'll just stop sharing i think or not
just must be about somehow yeah yeah
okay
um
all good so i've only i've just i know
we're short on time so i've just chucked
in um two or three quick slides here
um
this is really just an overall general
report of the season we are getting the
accounts audited et cetera as we needed
to do uh that's all in process at the
moment so when we get that we'll get
through uh we just wanted the chance to
update you where we're at while it's all
still fresh
um
if we
just look at our site plan um the site
went really well for us
uh the car park went really well after a
few of those wet days we managed to get
some gravel in there uh when it was
really wet over new years
uh which
improved the entry but now it worked
really well as a car park and
uh we often on our busy days would
expand up into the next next little bay
and sort of send um sort of elderly and
what have you that were dropping kids
off up into that area
uh a service worked really well for our
contractors they could come in and out
um
pretty happy with that
we were quite low where our dock was we
did have a bit of flooding there so we
invested in some aquatic carpet towards
the end of the season that just helped
us make that work
um but yeah the yellow is where we ran
the cable um and it's something we might
could look at expanding but as mark said
we want to add stuff for the younger
kids that didn't quite have the
confidence and then maybe that they can
enter that straight off the dock
and then also probably something for the
bigger kids they want a wee bit more
excitement there's a couple of um
sort of next level up ones we could look
at so that's sort of
uh
on the actual part within the area that
right at the moment some of the
improvements
um
but if i just
you heard mark expand on what else can
we do so we're
looking around the world at different
options of what we can do we're
investigating a
floating surf option at the moment uh
that also has the potential to aerate
the pond and improve the water uh that's
through a connection of the people that
have already supplied us the park so
that would be a first in australasia i
believe um
but something we're investigating and at
the bottom is mark on the cable day so
we just simply put a jump on the pontoon
and a transportable cable
um but we're looking at how could we
make that work
also a lot of interest from people in
campus camping and glamping
and we're keen to see what the council
is going to do with the proposed part
down the road but can we do a bit of a
trial of that next season could we put
three or four in our car park the people
that are going to use our park so this
is just really an image mood board of uh
some of those things we want to
investigate could they work for next
year and the last one there's additional
community amenities i haven't really got
a drawing
um but we really want to look at can we
put in bathrooms can we put in that sort
of thing we ran out of time i believe
for the tiff funding uh where we could
have worked with the mahinga kai team
and can we get some toilets in there
sooner rather than later
and
could they be slightly more than toilets
and provide some more shower amenities
and etc for the community it then
becomes a legacy for the mahing akai so
lots of ideas would like to push around
now that we've got some time
all right deflated and clean of the park
took four days um
but yeah massive thanks to a little team
that helped
um in my final word on the park and tony
will give you a very quick upland update
on wow across the river it's just a big
thank you to the community from the
people that come in of scones when we
were setting up to the dog walkers that
didn't like us for a start but by the
end of it we've become great mates just
those habitual people we're there every
day they are there every day
um
we seem to have turned a lot of people's
attitudes towards it but just the
laughter
and the enthusiasm and the joy of the
families was was really awesome so we're
we're very keen um
how can we keep improving that and how
can we test things for when we want to
move across the river
so just quickly um i'll hand over the
tony just a slide there to quickly
remind you what our big vision is about
yeah just before i jump on that thanks
jose
thanks the opportunity to to talk
tonight um and just give you a bit of a
report um
just to uh clarify one of mark's
comments he said about seven ton of
debris that came off out of the pond uh
slight overstatement it was about 700 kg
i think um but uh anyway he's not
probably used to um putting
that on the uh on the table anyway but
uh no 700 kg not seven tons and i went
to the christchurch city council
landfill you'll be happy yeah
so um
look that that's a great uh great great
place to um
step off from joe smith um the aspect
about the transitional um
we've always seen the um the park where
we are at the moment is a transitional
space and that's why the lease is what
it is with the idea of the of the bigger
picture um and obviously
in our bigger picture we had wave and
aquaplay and white water and white which
is up on your screen um we've sort of
got that transitional thing going with
the uh the aquaplay um and we've just
sort of just and obviously tested on
that open a bit of a that last day a wee
bit of a demonstration around weight
but i suppose in this environment that
we're in at the moment with covert and
so forth and uncertainty and are we are
we able to get overseas and all that
sort of thing which is only just
starting to
unlock now it's been an interesting
period of time and uh
um from an investor
and from an investment perspective and
putting investment into
these sorts of things there is a wee bit
of reluctance at this time um and
um just because of the nature of tourism
and so forth people aren't um
there's not the security i suppose of
that um but it's
with it's been done it's been completed
um as a transitional space and what
we've been trying to do is going hey
how can we
continue to
prove the concept prove the project uh
as uh as appropriate for kaipui and how
can we do transitional things to
actually just start kicking those goals
we've done it on the aqua play with
start and
as jase alluded to with looking at hey
how can we do a transitional um aqua
play uh cable on there maybe a there's
an inflatable um uh
surf rider thing which uh gives a bit of
a kickstart into what's gonna
potentially happen over the over the
other side of the river um none of those
things are actually real built
structures they're able to be inserted
in the same way and taken away as we've
done with the aquaplay um but it just
starts to
prove what it is that we're doing so on
that if we have a bit of a think about
the other side of the river for a minute
um
we had a memorandum of understanding all
we do um with uh ymac um
which actually was signed up a couple of
years ago now and um is uh coming up for
either i've renewal of some description
um uh in august this year and i suppose
we'll be wanting to have a chat with the
the staff and obviously yourselves
in the near future about how can we
actually extend that
for for a period of um three years
because we are wanting to progress
things um so there's a
an extension of that uh memorandum is
something that we'll be looking to um uh
to do uh in the short term um but also
as well as that
there's uh
the investors that have put dollars into
the um uh the equiply
um
this this year are keen to actually
progress
the cable and aquaplate um and part of
that is
which is fantastic um
so
on one hand we're asking for an
extension for the memorandum of
understanding for a period uh to keep
that uh security in there uh we're also
probably wanting to look to get a slice
of that pie that's up on the up on the
screen there
is a
way of going
how do we
at the moment there's a number of funds
out there additional funding for like
pgf and so forth jackie that um
that actually requires sort of uh
milestones to be
real and attainable and
they're less
likely to actually provide funding if
you can't prove that the project's
actually going to happen so some of
those things around consenting leases
ownership all that sort of thing
helps in those applications and actually
going hey this is real and actually is
happening otherwise they don't tend to
actually take you as serious as as you
would like to so i suppose
um
we'll be wanting to progress some
applications with um the likes of the uh
second
uh
it isn't called pgf but it's the sort of
second version of pgf that's out there
at the minute um and
we need to really probably be going in
front of them um in the next sort of six
or nine months um as far as going hey
we've got this in line
um and actually start to actually
develop the project um for an equiply in
cable park on the other side um with
hopefully getting a shovel on the ground
late next year
very good okay oh well congratulations
on the project i mean it's been amazing
and it has been far more successful i
think than anyone thought it was going
to be
so anything i'm hoping anything that the
council can do to help you
progress this so that you can get to
those funders and and impress them with
what you've done so far
um i'm sure that we've got lots of
support from the board does anyone on
the board have any questions they'd like
to ask tony or jason
brent
thank you madam chair i'm most impressed
with the number of out-of-town visitors
guys really impressive at the 15 000.
um i could we could actually hear across
the river the people yelling and
screaming so that's an indication of how
much fun there was being had over there
um how many return visitors did you have
and the second question in terms of were
there any issues injuries that sort of
stuff
thanks
uh so
first question return visitors we
haven't
pulled the data on that yet but they
were quite a lot um
you know you hear them i went last time
last time we did this or they're coming
back but yeah we will get the numbers on
that
uh injury has been through serious
injuries and probably
half a dozen minor sort of sprains and
things but yeah we had two leg breaks
and we had a
um what was considered at the time of
serious uh um back injury but it ended
up a bruised tailbone
from a young fella that
created a new creative line on one of
the slides
but yeah
two leg injuries a low a low level and a
knee
but wasn't through failure of the um
things it was sort of
bad luck and one had a wee bit of
pre-existing history
um had a bit of um
yeah but a bit of um but burn i suppose
you'd call it friction burn
um and sort of learn learning to pre-wet
a lot of the slides and things like that
especially on hot days so there's a bit
of learning
uh but no generally we were you know we
were waiting and waiting and waiting um
and also the staff were amazing when
they we had a few nurses on board so on
those serious ones
um
yeah i was very very proud of the staff
and the way they handled it
very good
any other questions from anyone
now well look thank you very much for
your presentation as i say it's very
impressive um
i've certainly heard people in the
community who have done a complete 180
on this whole thing there was quite a
bit of opposition but now everyone seems
to love it and as you said the sound of
laughter you can't beat that can you so
that's fantastic and it sounds as if
you've got an awful lot for us to look
forward to as well so well done guys
thank you very much
we really want to see how we can get
those twenty four thousand people into
kaiapoi and not driving away that's
probably the one thing for both parties
to work on yeah but yeah thank you for
your time
thank you okay
thank you
thank you very much
okay
all right
moving on
now adjourned business
report 6.1 the approval to consult on
speed limit review for smith street kai
point we've got shane sitting there
waiting over to shane
and that's a bit of a tough act to
follow going from excitement in the
water to reducing speed limits so
apologies for that
but trust me you've had a chance to read
the report we're looking at a pretty
substantial change in environment with
the new development going in off of
hakara road and tunis street i actually
have plans for the traffic fix signals
in for engineering review so the
developer on that south
southeast quadrant is
is getting ready to go gangbusters on
construction and given that we will be
seeing a lot more traffic in the area
new traffic signals um and uh footpath
immediately against the road we feel
that it is high time that this area be
looked at for a speed limit whether the
sealant is appropriate or should be
dropped so we are looking for
permission to go out to consultation on
that
thank you shane
any questions
i i have a question um it might be more
for chris i'm not sure um
i was interested to read that the
supermarket in a department store it's
actually there in black and white and i
have to say it's the first time i've
seen it in black and white it's almost
become a bit of an urban myth
um so can you tell me is there a
timeline for either of these
developments to start
does anyone know quest you know
i had a conversation with simon hart
today
um and he
um
was a little bit more
uh firm around um the fact that a
supermarket was going to go into there
um and talked about some land purchase
and things like that which may have
happened in there um not so
um
certain around
um whether or not a department store was
going to go in there and he wasn't aware
of anything firm around the department
store but but definitely the the
supermarket he was a bit more a bit more
certain on i don't know around
timeframes i'm sorry
okay no that's right i thought that
would be the answer but i thought i'd
just check
philip followed by martin
uh hello shane um who's funding the
traffic signals
the traffic signals are being designed
and constructed by the developer doing
the works on that southeast quadrant
thank you
martin
phillip preempted me so i'll withdraw my
hand
right
hence you're disappearing yellow hand
that's the one
all right um
okay well i'll um
move this recommendation that the board
receives the report
um so that's a
b approves consultation
c d e
f and g do i have a seconder
i'm more than happy to second that madam
chair all right second of five brent
okay um
obviously this is something that does
need to be done
um
it's just a matter of of when and
suppose now is this sort of time as any
because all the other um speed limits
also being changed and it seems a
logical um change to to be made as well
bren did you want to say anything
thank you madam chair only to the extent
that having traffic lights in this
particular area is an indication that we
are going to see an increase in people
coming into the area and
potential growth in the area in kaiapoi
and i'm all in favor of that thank you
madam chair
thank you i think this isn't necessarily
that the traffic lights are going ahead
is it it's just the speed limit change
really
well
oh no it says any speed limit change
will not be implemented before the
traffic so okay i stand corrected
all right so i moved it france seconded
it all those in favor say aye
aye against
carrie all right thank you very much
shane that was quick and easy thank you
for your time
right moving on to 6.2 the town center
lighting concepts and themes for renewal
and kaipoy
i'd just like to say that chris
greengrass was on this um
working group
um
and
since she
resigned well since she stood down from
being chair
a number of meetings were meant to be
held but in actual fact they were always
cancelled so unfortunately i was meant
to be the rep on this so i know i don't
know any more than anyone else does
about what's on here although i have
spoken to chris about it and i did check
with chris and she seems quite happy
with what's happened here because she
was certainly the one that was um
following it up so vanessa thank you
good evening welcome
thank you
um so the purpose of this report is
really just to seek the board members
endorsement of the town center feature
lighting designs or rengar and kaiboy um
you may recall that um or the surface i
should say the designs are actually
prepared by kevin cooley from total
lighting limited and he was selected by
the town center feature lighting
working group as the preferred
consultant to do work in that space you
may remember he came in i believe and
did a session with the board um i'm just
showing you some lights and and various
effects that can be achieved
the concepts are really just intended to
guide future town centering center
lighting decisions
from a design and funding point of view
going forward and really just to provide
uh businesses and property owners a
child a design guide i guess if they're
looking to do upgrades to their own
stores and properties
the budgets are out of date at the
moment so they will be subject to review
going forward when we look at
progressing different upgrades and i um
should also mention you know there is an
option to look at a suite of options
there so if
if there was a desire to keep the
project within budget if it happened to
go over to to deliver the full um suite
of options that kevin's put in the
proposal you can always pick and choose
and take some things out so happy to
take questions
sorry about that um thanks vanessa does
anyone have any questions of vanessa
oh phillip
and then brent
hi thanks nisa
one of the things that has changed since
kevin first did his report
um i think the community board is now
looking at changing the balance rights
on the bridge
which isn't reflected in kevin's report
and i must say that i i actually don't
mind the balustrades as they are they'd
make a nice lighting feature i just
wondered whether there could be any
input from kevin
into the balustrades so that we can do
both together if there is a change
so the lighting and any change to the
balustrades go together and we don't
just end up with something that can't be
lighted or lit up
uh yeah that's the point so i've
actually spoken to kevin just to preempt
this meeting to see if there were any
lighting design changes that need to be
done if we were to upgrade the
balustrades and that's another report
just so you know i'm coming forward
coming to see you guys soon around there
in terms of the options there uh he's
actually said the lighting that he's
proposed already in in the concept
designs there was a little bit a bit of
a mention around the bridge and the kai
poi concept design will still stand as
is for the
proposed balustrade option that we're
putting forward so there was no need to
change that but we did um check with him
sorry my cat's just jumping up the
curtain at the moment and shredding it
in the background
but we are looking at taking a master
plan approach to this so there were
three separate projects painting the
william street bridge
upgrading the balustrades potentially
and also doing the street light review
so we're tying them all together in the
background so we can get synergies and
cost efficiencies across all three of
those at the same time um so work will
be completed um in a way that's a bit
more logical um yeah in terms of getting
the best outcome
i just wanted to be certain that the
right hand knew what the left was doing
and if you if you're doing all two or
three aspects
so
solve that problem vanessa
great
can i just add that the community board
have never seen anything on the
balustrades that has not come to the
board at all
yeah you're aware of that that's good
it's only been to council hasn't it
that's right and i think initially there
was a six options were taken to council
last year in a briefing purely just to
get a steer as to what might be
amenable from a budget point of view and
design point of view the intention was
always then to follow that through with
the community boards and get endorsement
from the boards
we took those six options in march last
year and the council asked us to go away
and look at some other additional
options which we did this year so we
took back some additional options in
march this year and they have selected a
preferred
design that um that is quite
contemporary but it sort of maintains
that heritage component as well so i'll
be bringing that forward through to you
and ideally i think may i'm aiming for
yeah
very good thank you very good are there
any other questions
brent
thank you madam chair uh i also was
wanting to know more about the
balustrade and whether or not there was
options to change and is it possible
vanessa for you to uh to send the
presentation that was given to council
through the community board
in the first instance and then the next
question i have is with regard to the
lighting underneath underneath the
bridge i was always under the impression
there was an issue with the amount of
feces that is dumped by the volume of
birds underneath there that makes it a
real problem uh to actually put lighting
under there so is that being taken into
account please
i certainly can happy to see that
presentation on um just noting that a a
full report will follow that so just
just so you know that i'm not too sure
about the faeces issue to be honest it
hasn't been it hasn't come up since i've
had the project um but it's something
i'll have to have a discussion with with
other staff and our lighting designer
yeah
thank you for nasa would someone like to
move
i'm ready to move thanks madam chair
so that's a through to f
as a seconder john your second there
you see
um bram would you like to speak to it
only to the extent that uh venice you've
done a good job thank you
john
i don't agree with brent there's
positive a very very positive direction
that we're moving into and and um
i like like brent um i think that the
community board is probably at this at
this point we start to um
to look at those um
you know the options if you like at the
ballast trades and so on but now now's
the time to do it thank you
congratulations for the effort it's good
thank you all right so moving 6.2 a
through to f moved by brent seconded by
john all those in favor
i
against
carried thank you vanessa that's well
done thank you
okay
6.3 ratification of the board submission
to the council and environment
canterbury's draft annual plans
i'll move that the cardboard to a heavy
community board a receives the report
b
retrospectively ratifies it and oh both
of for b and c do i have a seconder
well i'll see john seconded by john
okay
all right
we had a fair bit of con
discussion about this um with the
airwaves in the end because we never
ever got together on this of course it's
all been by zoom
and i hope that everyone was happy with
the final submissions so i'd like to
move 6.3 a b and c seconded by john all
those in favor
aye
against
carried
thank you
right there's no correspondence my
report of verbal update um as soon as
the last meeting was only three weeks
ago and in that time
i've been isolating with covert
i haven't done much except rest so
um the only things that i would like to
bring up is the fact that i did attend
um
a special ceremony to bruce kearney
principal of kaipur high school
put on by president neil price of the
rsa in thanking bruce for the fantastic
cooperation between the school and the
rsa as you're well aware now the numbers
that turn up numbers of kids that turn
up to those events is awesome
and the speeches that are given um the
kids are given the opportunity to speak
at those events it certainly turned the
whole anzac day parade thing around and
so bruce was given a really beautifully
handmade trophy
and he was um he had to read the oath
before the last post it was a really
lovely ceremony
um
you me we us have got back into action
now that um
we're all back in action
and not in
lockdowns quite so much anymore and
we've got a new festival this year
matariki which is on the
24th of june
firework display and night market um so
that's a new event a new annual event
for you for all together carpool sorry i
used their wrong name atk
um
a new event for them
um which hopefully will be as big as any
of the other events that we've held in
the past and they're also planning the
spring festival as well which isn't that
far away amazingly enough
september
um
other than that i don't think i've got
anything to report so
i will
um
i meant to recommend that you receive my
report do i have a seconder for that
please
thank you al seconded by al all those in
favor
all right
against carried thank you
and i'm sure that um courtney you'll
remove the wooden theft and community
board mistake that's
in that motion
okay nine matters referred for
information
um i'll move the recommendation that the
board receives the information items
nine point one to nine point six
second to please
have you seen gone second if i john all
those in favor
aye against carried thank you right
we're up to members information exchange
so looking at my screen we'll start with
the top left hand corner
philip that's you on my screen
ah oh i haven't actually uh prepared
anything this month but i can say that
creative communities of which you're
aware madam chair uh we have 22 or 23
applications for funding
and the committee will be meeting later
this week to consider those um otherwise
it's been a reasonably busy time and
i've been busy doing other things so
very brief this month
thank you phillip
i'm john you're next
thanksgiving chair um
sorry i missed the last meeting that's
first and foremost i don't know how that
happened but i just whether i'll ever
know i couldn't get the thing to work um
the um
took part in the in the um
uh
discussion and working out and so on for
the submissions to the
to the plans
um
probably the biggest thing that i've
been involved with over this last um
well a couple of months really is the uh
is the dandy club and we should
and you should all really be very very
proud of this district
and the volunteers that belong to um
look after the diamond club
you know i've been down there lots of
times it's it's basically
the venue part of it has closed has been
closed for ages and then and the
the pressure the clients run 104 of them
currently i think
the pressure that they've been under and
the
frustration
and the anxiety they they want to come
back
basically they they want to come back
they're missing they get they're missing
the organization the volunteers
and the effort they're putting in
if for example
the clients were there two days a week
they get in the midday meal
um they're still getting there
the the staff two teams of staff
um
are
cooking meals for them and taking them
out
having a little chat
and making contact through that way with
with all of them
um
the ones that that are prepared to talk
to them over the phone are doing that
so
it's a big job they're saying that the
volunteers are still working hard
and in some cases
under more pressure because of the um
the environment
and i hope that it gets back to normal
sooner than later but it's something to
be proud of the fact that i had been
close to it
over that side of it and really seen it
from the inside when they're under
pressure
we're part of a good community thank you
thank you john that sounds amazing
sandra
thank you
just a couple of brief items that of
interest um
uh environment canterbury through the
zone committee
zone committee allocated its 50 000
for projects
in the area and the particular one for
um
oh there's two actually um is
a spawning habitat enhancement in the
taranaki stream and also um
willow clearance in the pines wetland um
they probably add up to about
30 000 worth of the
50 000.
so um and there's a few other projects
but those are the two main ones that
affect um this area
the other thing that was of concern to
me um as you know um
most of pc7 plan change seven is now
operative there's
some appeals going on but the bulk of it
is being ticked off and now operational
um we were waiting um
for the alpine rivers section of the
existing canterbury land and water
regional plan
which which concerns the minimum flows
in the waimakariri itself
and that was still to be reviewed
but now um under the um
national policy statement fresh water
ecan has to produce a new
um land water regional plan by 2024
so it's not planning to do the review
of the alpine rivers section as a
separate entity which we were waiting
for because
um the saltwater intrusion into the
um
kaiapoi is directly linked to the
um too lower flow in the waimakariri so
i'm going to ask um
simon markham how
we get
um
into the process um of the preparation
of the
new regional plan which has to be
notified by 2024
um
and i don't know yet because certainly
there'll be a view in the community
about
the flow minimum flow in the waimakari
and how it affects
the kaiapoi um and the rivers upstream
yeah that's
all me martin thank you sandra
thank you thank you madam chair um
we had a
community well-being board meeting at
the end of march and um
main topic of discussion was just the
uncertainty around funding for some of
the programs that we're offering
very very frustrating
and particularly ones coming from msd in
the health board
the only good news we had was that the
mana archi program which is the
mental health support program for
uh primary age tamariki
has got funding through to december um
but then there's no certainty after that
so
yeah we're really up in the air about
that
um
last week we had a joint promotions
association meeting um which vanessa and
simon uh hosted with joan um
and one of the things that
came from that meeting was that vanessa
and simon and the
town centre's team are looking for ideas
about how we can rejuvenate at the town
centres encourage people to get back in
coming shopping
we've flicked through some ideas to
vanessa and simon and joan
but if you've got any ideas about
what the council could do to help that
process plea please talk to vanessa
um
last week we also had a
cleaning session for kpa
as you mentioned jackie the easing of
restrictions on outside events is just a
godsend we just um you know we can now
get on and play any things um you know
up until that happened you know all
events were going to have to fenced off
and people were scanning in and out and
um i just was just going to be a
nightmare so it's just great that that's
that's
those restrictions are coming off
and lastly i've just been working with
the green space team looking at public
access uh upstream of the carpory
railway river bridge
up through the
that part of the cowboy and into the
hocus stream area um there's a few
barriers there with kiwi rail and
private ownership um that just we're
assisting the green space team on and um
hopefully we can get a license to occupy
from kiwi rail um so that people can get
access through that air area
without the risk of being considered to
be trespassers
so that's me
sorry brent
thank you madam chair i've already sent
through my report uh i would just like
to make a comment with regard to john
and the donnelly club dawn and tania and
the volunteers just do an amazing job uh
shirley's mum and dad attended donnelly
and they just thought it was the best
thing since sliced bread so
pass on our thanks to dawn and tony and
the volunteers please john
only other thing apart from the report i
sent through was beech grove residents a
couple of them requested my presidents
with regard to
you may recall
the board meeting a couple of months ago
with regard to parking in beech grove
and the residents were wanting me to see
firsthand the issues that the residents
are having there
for every 12 houses there's effectively
three car parks
when one house has five cars uh where do
they park and there's a major major
issue
two weeks ago an ambulance tried to
attend a resident and beach grove and
they couldn't down get down the road
so
yeah that's a real issue so all of that
information has been passed on to staff
but i wanted to just give you an update
thank you madam chair
thanks brent
and that leads us with al
yeah thank you madam chair um i've got
very little to report i've had with this
stupid bug i've hardly been off the
property for over two weeks so i don't
have the clue what's going on really um
nice new boat in the river you've all
have seen um as a a liverboard um
penny and kevin living on that and
there's another one coming soon about
the same size again so the whole thing
is some get going you look starting to
look really good um we've covered aqua
land so that the fairy the fairy forest
at pines debacle um but not debacle pr
debacle i should say um
we had a meeting last week we were to
have a meeting last week to try and sort
out um
what happens next and that was cancelled
because two of us had covered and um so
so nothing to report yet just just
letting you know we still will have a
council uh an in-house council a debrief
if you like that's the right word just
to find out what happened and then we'll
decide what um if anything we can do to
try and um remedy the situation
um that's really about me lots of things
happening down at tikka haka but i'll
leave that till next month and when the
when they've been confirmed and and fill
you in on that so um i'll croak off and
leave that'll do for me think
thanks al um just a couple of things i
forgot to mention before um
i met with wearing another hat i met
with the guys who want to do the disc
golf so
i have actually written an article for
the advocate about it but i have put in
the article that they still have to get
permission from the community board and
they're well aware of that um
they're very enthusiastic though it was
fantastic to hear their plans for the
kaiapoi domain
um
and the other thing is al mentioned this
to me the other day
i think the church
one of the churches some of the churches
are doing something for the queen's
jubilee queen's birthday her 17th year
he wondered if the community board
wanted to do anything i have to say it's
not something that's high on my list of
things to do but i did wonder if maybe
there was anything that was happening in
the community round about that time
that might like um
you know i don't know a bit of glamour
what would you call it a bit of royalist
stuff attached to it someone would have
planted a tree is someone planting a
tree could we call it the jubilee tree
or something i don't know so if anyone
knows of anything
or has a bright idea about how we could
do something i'm certainly happy to
consider it but um i don't know about
actually making a special event for it
but you know just think about that
anyway let me know if you've got any
bright ideas
okay thank you very much everyone so
that's members information exchange
moving on we've just got the
consultation project migrant experiences
regeneration projects board funding
update balance at 4th of april
general landscaping budget 25 430.
media items well there's going to be an
article about the disc golf in the paper
but it hasn't been to the board yet so
sorry about that
um no questions understanding orders or
urgent general business and so it looks
like i can declare the meeting closed at
10 minutes to 6. it's probably not a
record but it could be
well done
thank you everyone for your attendance
anything anyone else wants to say
no
uh chris
chris are we talking tomorrow morning 11
well we can do hell if you feel
i've got a few things to discuss thing
we haven't been near the building for
about a century um
what time suits you
every time says you i'm pretty
[Music]